-My next guest is an Emmy-
and Grammy-nominated comedian
who has a new animated
stand-up special
called "Tig Notaro: Drawn"
which premieres July 24th
at 10:00 p.m. on HBO
and will also be available
on HBO Max.
Please welcome Tig Notaro!
-♪ It's Tig Notaro,
the girl is incredible ♪
♪ She's animated
in a TV show called "Drawn" ♪
♪ It's Tig Notaro
changing up her tune ♪
♪ Might not recognize her
'cause now she's a cartoon ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-It's a very big move.
-Tig Notaro.
That's Tig Notaro right there.
-How come --
How come you didn't have me on
to do that game?
[ Laughter ]
-"The Mimic"? I didn't know
that you could do, uh, sounds.
-Yeah, well, I'm known for them.
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't know
that you were known for them.
There's other things
that I think you were known for,
but sounds -- you doing --
mimicking sounds?
-Yes.
For instance,
this is a spring.
Doi-oi-oi-oi-oi-oing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Bell dings ]
[ Applause ]
The next one
is a curtain opening.
-[ Laughing ] Okay.
-[ Sniffing sharply ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Bell dings ]
♪♪
-[ Laughing ]
That's really good.
-Thank you.
-That's really well done.
I love that one. Yeah.
-Well, prepare yourself,
because...
[ Laughter ]
...this is a clown horn.
[ Honks, wheezes ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitating horn honking ]
[ Bell dings ]
-Whoa, why didn't we do that?
We should have had Tig
play the game.
You could have played against
Tom Hiddleston and crushed him.
[ Imitates horn honk ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitating horn honking ]
-I got you. I heard you, yeah,
I -- Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
You -- Tig,
your kids just turned 5.
-They did. They turned 5.
-Yeah, and you posted
this revelation
that they had
about getting older.
-Mm-hmm.
-And I thought it was touching.
I thought it was nice.
-Well, yeah,
they were in preschool.
You know, when the pandemic
started, they were 3.
We pulled them out
and kept them home.
And then they were
returning to a new school
that was starting
with summer school
that was going to just
turn into junior kindergarten.
And they are 5 now.
And when they saw
their old backpacks hanging,
they said, "Uh, we are not
bringing our old backpacks.
Those are for babies."
-I'm so sad. I mean,
here's the old backpack.
-Yeah. They were like, "No way.
We are big boys now.
We're not bringing
our old backpacks."
-So you got them new backpacks.
-Well, they had these,
but they dug them out,
because they realized
they were the big boy backpacks,
and so they wanted
to start bringing those now.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So, it's goodbye, childhood.
Hello, real world.
[ Laughter ]
-That's was the cutest --
Come on.
That's the best thing ever.
-And if you could go in closer,
it has little feet dangling
for when they get to the office,
you know?
-Absolutely, right?
I thought that was so cute.
I want to talk about
"Tig Notaro: Drawn."
-Yeah.
-This is your stand-up special,
but the whole thing is animated.
-Yeah, it's fully animated
and --
-Where'd you get
the idea for this?
-Well, it's been around,
animating stand-up.
In fact, you know,
there's TV shows,
and other comedians have used it
in their specials, and my --
-I haven't seen
a full special, though.
-No, I think
not start to finish.
There's no actual, live Tig
in the special.
-It is fantastic,
'cause there's a bunch
of different Tigs in this.
There's different
versions of you.
-Yeah. It's really interesting
when people draw you,
because it's flattering,
but it's also
like, "Oh.
That's how you see me."
[ Laughter ]
Or, "Am I that unattractive?"
-No, stop. Come on.
-You know?
-Stop it.
-I mean, it's just a funny thing
when you see yourself.
-Yeah.
-Because it truly is flattering.
-This is "Tig Notaro: Drawn."
Take a look at this.
-And there was this woman
that annoyed me to no end.
And when I was cleaning up,
sweeping, she was talking to me,
and I rarely paid attention
to what she said.
And this was so long ago.
And she was, like, going on and
on about dinosaurs
and how they were, you know,
eating people.
And I was like, "Wait, what?
Why are we just
standing here --"
And she's like, "Yeah,
like, scientists, you know,
took an insect
and took the blood and --"
And I was like,
"And they're just running around
eating people."
She's like, "Yes,
I can't believe
you haven't heard about this."
Had no idea
it was "Jurassic Park."
[ Laughter ]
-Tig Notaro.
Check out "Tig Notaro: Drawn"
July 24th at 10:00 p.m. on HBO
and streaming on HBO Max.